shocking moment Tennessee High School
student pepper sprays teacher twice
after he confiscated her phone in class
and there's a lot here some people
associate this with the the increase in
crime recklessness the uh the the
collapse of authority in our
institutions and I thought it was
interesting because we're talking about
whether or not this woman was justified
in pepper spraying this soy boy teacher
who collapsed and falls to his knees
after getting pepper spray for taking
her phone and I just find the whole
thing interesting the first point is
just you know our schools are messed up
don't don't have your kids in these
schools and the second thing is to what
degree should we entertain the authority
of these of these teachers
let's just start with this a Tennessee
High School teacher pepper sprayed twice
by a student assault took place at
Antioch High School outside of Nashville
reports indicate the teacher had taken
the student's phone and I'm pretty sure
she says in the video give me back my
phone so what do you guys think yeah
well I think I mean it's a microcosm for
all the things that are wrong right so
we have one we have an absence of
masculinity because I had teachers that
if you took something if you took
something from you that was going to be
your problem right it didn't matter if
you had pepper spray I I had a I had a
guy that was in my high school who was
our disciplinarian he literally had like
held a guy up by his throat against the
wall should you do that no it was a
private school so we could get away with
certain things and people wanted that of
their kids because he stepped out of
line so he had the physical ability to
dominate and this guy gets dominated by
a chick with a with a pepper spray
that's not a good not a good look but
you made an interesting point and I
agree with it people have a lot of
personal information on their phones and
that guy is an agent of the government
that's the thing that I hadn't thought
of so is he is he representing a an
unlawful search and seizure there under
the Fourth Amendment even because
there's some interesting he's
representing certain authorities in
power as a member of a of a government
is the government before the show when
we were pulling up these stories I said
this would be rich and really
interesting to talk about because I got
to tell you if I was in a school and
someone I don't care who teacher
otherwise tried taking my iPhone you be
prepared for me to physically defend
myself there there was no circumstance
for me in in you know after a certain
age I suppose where a teacher would ever
get away with anything like that yeah
man I'm like I'm 13 years old if they
try taking my Pokemon from me I'd be
like I'll leave the building before you
touch my property so we're talking about
a cell phone this teacher this is a
common Trope like the teacher takes the
phone away you're not touching my phone
I got private messages in there you got
you got messages with with your parents
in there and the teacher's like I'm
gonna take that from you ain't touching
it I will leave before I let you do that
when he grabbed her phone from her
that's theft that's seizure by the you
we point out the government uh I hadn't
thought about it until we were literally
in the moment here yeah there is some
interesting implications about that and
I do think that the correct answer is
send her out of the room look you're
being a distraction you've been removed
from the classroom I'm done with you go
deal with the administration that's
their job then you go back to teaching
that's probably the right move so we've
got a couple of mistakes like right
we're we're like five stops down from
where things shouldn't have happened has
this always been the case that teachers
would take something from the students I
think it depends on so there are certain
places especially private schools where
you sign away you know your parents your
minders your your um the people that are
the authority your power of attorney are
going to say that they have certain
authorities to do certain things like
that and you know when I was a kid like
we didn't have that like there was no my
cell phone that I had which I think I
got when I was 17 was attached to a car
and the only way you were bringing it is
you were bringing the whole thing in it
came out of the console so that wasn't a
real possibility and that was I was an
outlier most people didn't have that
that capability uh that being said I
don't think you should get pepper
sprayed and hit your knees with your
back to your enemy and cover yourself
and cry like a woman that that is very
offensive to me as a dude I just I just
it's troubling to watch someone go do
that kind of action it's like hey man
you lost your man card too not only did
you lose to a chick but you lost your
man card and now no one's gonna look at
you again yeah a cop should just I mean
the the uh teacher should have just
kicked her out let her keep her phone
get out of here yep leave I mean it's
probably gonna be kicking her out every
day and you're gonna end up kicking her
out of school because she's probably not
going to listen tomorrow she'll be back
she didn't look like like she could take
Direction no based on her her
interactions but also as you mentioned I
don't know what's you mentioned the
possibility that we're talking about
someone probably 16 to 18 based on the
high school right and she was an older
high school student
um she's got private photos she may have
private photos which we could uh we
don't have to discuss the nature of but
probably would be actually a crime to
possess uh if you're a dude so that's
not something you want to get it's just
like these bad actions but it's also
funny when like she pepper sprays him
and he just falls to his knees it hurts
me it hurts my masculinity like I want
him to go chop wood like he needs to
grow up beer he has a beard too doesn't
he
yeah he said there you go watch he's
like running from her yes he needs to
shave his face immediately and she's
like papilla peaches like walking
casually oh did they skip the part where
he falls to his knees no it's coming at
the end she sprays what is what is he
doing this is look at this there she
gets him oh down surrender fail turns
his back what is hey maintain control of
the phone that's the only upside to this
guy is that he held onto the property so
he won that minor minor Victory while
losing his man card that's wild yeah and
people around him are like I just got
pepper spray too you know the thing
about pepper spray it's a very imprecise
uh defensive weapon it sprays all over
it is the worst in fact I remember going
through the academy and everybody has to
get sprayed with it but the one thing
they said is like here's your pepper
spray now put it somewhere where you'll
never use it because it's awful if you
ever use it like when you see a guy like
on a search warrant if you're trying to
subdue a subject and they're like I got
this I'm gonna nobody wants that
happening it's everybody everybody Burns
everything it sucks people think it's
like it gets in your mucus membranes it
burns but on your skin you're irritated
you're like I remember taking a shower
afterwards and my neck was burning yeah
like this is terrible but yeah when we
were in uh we're at the j17 riots was it
J no no J 20th uh riots in 2017 when
Trump was getting inaugurated I was
there too and we were you know me and
Luke are like drenched in pepper spray
God you go take a shower afterwards and
it just burns it just reactivates yeah
it just reactivates it's burning all
over 100 I don't know man I saw this
story I thought it was yeah this is way
worse by the way what is it yes yeah the
the tear gas is Wayward for me when we
were in uh Ferguson the police were
using CS smoke so they called it yeah
tear gas and that's the stuff that fogs
and kind of lingers down there on you
and uh and CNN reported there was no
tear gas being fired it was just smoke
and uh it's because these are evil
people I'm pretty sure it was Don Lemon
so Ryan Riley was the guy who saw the
ear plugs that's right and thought they
were rubber bullets that's right he's
like he's probably watching he's one of
my biggest fans we were uh uh I'm on the
ground and we are gagging in tear gas
and I I started to pass out because I
got into a cloud of it and tunnel vision
starts forming it's a choking agent
right it's it's displacing the oxygen in
my lungs and then I fall down and I got
lucky some kids splashed water on my
face it's crazy craziest thing I I have
no idea so I'm in Ferguson tear gas
everywhere gunshots go off cops are like
go go run so I'm I'm running and I'm and
I walk through a cloud of tear gas
inhale it all and then all of a sudden
I'm like I can't I can't breathe I'm
like it's just my lungs aren't working
and then I'm like
and then I get tunnel vision where
everything starts turning black to a
point and then I just fall down the
grass on my back and the next thing I
know some kids splashes water my face
and I go
and I should have done that oh I don't
know how that kid knew
or maybe it was just fortunate yeah
splashing splashing water triggers the
uh the inhale reflex or whatever what's
crazy is we used to call that meeting
the wizard meeting the wizard yeah so
you've seen The Wizard of Oz right oh my
God people don't realize is that when
you start getting hypoxic like that and
I've been there too many times in a very
chaotic way but what happens is you lose
color vision first you don't know it
it's very Insidious hypoxia is an
Insidious yeah move so you lose the
color vision and then like you say you
get that Bugs Bunny at the end of the
Looney Tunes where it starts tightening
down it's all folks yeah and you're
looking you're looking through the loop
through the tunnel right and then that
goes out and what other people don't
realize too is when you do that in slow
motion especially if you're underwater
the last thing to go is is your auditory
nerves different nerves so you'll
actually stop being able to see but
you'll still hear so you can feel things
around you can hear things around you
but you can't see anything and then you
go out we call that meeting the wizard
because because that's when you go to Oz
right uh and then when you wake back up
like obviously like you had the kid
Splash you thank God and then you get
that that uh you know uh recovery and
you pop up and then everything kind of
comes back out once and you get you get
the color vision so that's kind of going
to Oz it's it's I don't know it's a
phenomenon that very few people can can
relate to if they haven't ever you can't
fake it you can only experience oh for
sure and I I wonder what would have
happened to me if that kid didn't wasn't
happening it was standing with a bottle
of water and he just poured it on my
face and I'm like like it was the
craziest thing and I'm like whoa and I
was like boom back everything was normal
again yeah goofy enough you've probably
got about two three minutes worth of uh
sitting there stagnant without breathing
even and you're still okay but it can
get bad fast and and that's why tear gas
is one of those things where it's an
area avoidance tool you can pivot to
what happened to January 6. they were
releasing the stuff and it was just
going everywhere and they were lobbing
it into the crowd and then they were
forcing the crowd into the barriers
right so it's that just tells me that
those people don't know how to use that
particular tool which is not their fault
they probably weren't training on it you
spray it where you don't want people to
be which is usually where you are and
then you put your mask on and then it's
an area denial as opposed to putting it
into people and making them run like you
did people don't understand too when I
was in Turkey
the police fired it into a tunnel and
the people just collapsed it's yeah like
there's no air anymore and they just
started falling down and then people
were like someone's got you gotta run in
there and drag them out don't breathe
yeah the the so the crazy thing too is
people don't realize that the stuff they
use in the US is nothing the stuff we
have rules here yeah in Brazil I was
like ah tear gas saying nothing and I'm
like oh I'm like mucus is just pouring
out of every orb that is my experience
yeah full on what they do for everybody
who goes through basic training so
anybody who's done military training has
seen this they don't do it the same way
for for cops as far as I know but some
guys get it but you go into like a
chamber and then they fill the chamber
up with smoke and you've got your mask
on and you're like this looks like a
really bad place to take off a mask and
then they tell you to take it off and
then you have to say a paragraph of some
kind usually it's a you know a rote
memory thing and you're going like and
you just have no ability to put any
you're like and you have to get out the
paragraph or they won't let you out so
the worst you know you're just kind of
fun though it's yes
Adrenaline Rush after you come out is
insane so when I rather been in because
I have everything empty out of my eyes
my ears my nose yeah
it's horrible when I went in there when
I was in they they make you take your
mask off and you have to wait for
everyone in the room to get the mask off
before you can put it on to clear it
then you take it off again and then you
say whatever it is then you put it on
again and clear it then they let you out
so you're standing there holding the
mask in front of your waiting for all
the idiots the donut that lick windows
and you know and you can then you can
hear the guy just go he's like we're
waiting on everyone we're waiting on and
you're sitting there dying wanting to
kill the person right so yeah it but
when you when you come out the
adrenaline and stuff after you survive
you're walking out and you feel like you
accomplished it's great you know the gas
that's used in Turkey was not as strong
as Brazil but it was so intense that the
mass we had didn't work at all I like
that you're a connoisseur of Cs gases oh
that's not a thing that everybody has in
their repertoire you should put that on
your own can you tell you about the
flavor profile that's right there's a
fine bouquet with a hint of all of it he
spits it back out clears his palette
with some water and spray it again
you're not actually supposed to swallow
it you're you know like it's like
tasting wine remember when Homer became
a mall cop and he pepper sprayed his
eggs
that's how it goes so one of the one of
the things I remember when I was in
Portland I went into one of the places
this is off duty so we're just like you
know we went to Whole Foods and got some
food we went to a you know Pub and stuff
like that and me and my buddies are
walking through and at some point we
went through some Park and there's all
the metal railings as you know as the Cs
dissipates it doesn't go away it just
comes out of the air and it settles so
you'll see it like on on railings and
every once in a while somebody will
touch the railing where the Cs was and
it activates where they'll get some of
the pepper spray and it activates on a
hand and so I just remember one of my
buddies was like in front of me going
down these stairs and then he reached
his hand up he goes don't touch that
rail and we're like what and he's like
it's spicy like you couldn't come up
with anything else but it was legit
spicy you watch him his hand is over
there and you go like oh yeah I don't
want this you can put on your eggs
you get your man card back if you if you
drop to your knees in a high school
after stealing a girl's phone and you
cry like a girl I think you get your man
card back if you put it on your eggs
like for like a week dude I remember
when I was like I'm gonna spend 12 or 13
and I was in my buddy's garage and he
had some pepper spray I was like what is
this and I just like sprayed it it was
it was horrible
exactly I didn't get the full effect of
like having it directly sprayed in my
face but it was not a fun experience I
was like okay now I understand why this
is used as a deterrent yeah yeah you
don't want yeah I just like that pepper
balls are I think relatively common now
in right control stuff and I've I've
been hit in the face with a pepper ball
Ricochet so when I was in Baltimore I
was the I think it was the Freddie gray
riots the cop for no reason me and two
other people clearly with cameras
filming he fired at something I think it
was aiming for my face but it hit
something to my left like the wall and
then sprayed plastic bits and and pepper
all into my face and I'm like did you
have glasses on no you knew now though
eye protection very crazy well normally
like like even in my old YouTube
pictures like with the goggles yeah and
I'm like on a roof in New York but you
don't know when to put the goggles on
and it sucks to put them on the whole
time exactly and then how would you
catch it would also wear the gas masks
on her neck and the goggles and it's
just like you want to try to avoid using
them because you want to maximize your
sensory you know for sure yeah you know
well that's the other thing most people
have those things and you see I saw
antifa guys in Portland and I don't know
maybe gals or maybe neither whatever
they wanted to identify us and they have
all that equipment but a lot of them if
you don't train in that stuff if you
don't spend time in it you're you're
lost because the second like imagine if
somebody just suddenly just gave you
just like a tube to look through and
you're like here's your new world yeah
and by the way you can't hear anything
which changes your balance it changes
your jaunt like the way you step the way
you identify cuts out your peripheral
vision you don't know who's standing
gear left ear right it gets very
dangerous they have those full face
masks where it's a sheet of plastic
basically over your face and those are
better but you still have barriers on
your left and your right so it's you
know looking through like you said like
a tunnel yeah well you imagine the guys
that are running out there with night
vision you're a security guy always tell
me about I got to invest and it's like
it's said you got to spend time now you
got to go buy walks with night vision on
just in your neighborhood you look like
a psychopath but you got to do it I've
got some nighttime Mischief so you might
be involved in nighttime Mischief as
long as you stay on the road right Tim
yeah I've got the soup the really
expensive one so like the Panos are they
the No No No Yeah it's like some Thirty
ones or something yeah I don't know what
they're called but uh very expensive
they're like 10 grand and they they sit
right here and you can't see around
they're you know they're awesome look up
at the sky you can see satellites yeah
it could be a spiritual experience for
people yeah it's looking at the sky
through night vision is that's what I
did with my mother-in-law I actually
shared it with my mother-in-law changed
her she was like this is incredible this
is worth the price yeah you could see
everything it's crazy get IR flashlights
for your guns now yeah so you put the IR
flashlights on right right and then when
you turn the light on only you can see
the light it's pitch black for everybody
else you know you can see the like well
the laser in there then you're set to
goons out thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time